Look, in honor
of you coming to my show,
I-I wanted
to make you feel at home,
and so I prepared
a little bit
of authentic Mexican cuisine
from one of our best taquerias,
uh, the Trump Grill.
(laughter)
These are actual bowls
from the Trump Grill.
Uh, I've been told it's, uh...
-it's divine.
-(laughs)
Yes.
I think Hispanics love it,
-is what I've heard.
-This is a fake.
-What?
-This is fake.
-That's fake? That is...
-Can I throw it on the floor?
-What? I...
-Yes?
-No, are you...? No!
-Okay.
-(cheering and applause)
-Wow.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
All right, you know what?
I see what you're gonna do.
I'm here to talk about
your book, because you want
to move on. That's what
this book is all about,
-is that right?
-Yes, sir.
Let's Move On.
I assume this is about the...
the Russian hoax?
Is that correct?
-Let's move on.
-Let's move on beyond this.
-Yes. -What message... You know,
so you're gonna come on
to my show. You're gonna...
you're gonna take a dump
on my stage, apparently.
Thanks a lot.
Thanks a lot, Mr. President.
The message... the message is,
if you're president,
behave like a president.
If you are leader of the world,
behave like the leader
of the world.
This is nonsense,
what we have here today.
It's a total mess.
Just look at that shutdown
of government.
Look at his, uh...
his comments around DACA.
I mean, a million kids
that have university degrees,
that been living in this nation,
that are a massive...
that are very powerful force.
I wish I can take them down
to Mexico,
the one million of them.
But I respect that they want
to live in this nation
because they have been here
for a long, long time.
But it's... that shows what kind
of a guy we have there.
Uh, I'm talking
about Trump, yes.
I understand
you're talking about Trump.
No, but, really, really,
I-I guess I'm trying to explain
to American public opinion
what Mexico's all about.
We're the 12th largest economy
in the world.
We have the largest
manufacturing block anywhere
in the world,
the most competitive.
We are partners
of this great nation.
And we have made this region--
Canada, United States,
and Mexico-- the most
competitive region in the world.
Otherwise, the four motor
companies-- the Chryslers--
would not be alive.
They went broke five years ago.
And the only way they came back
to business and to market
was by becoming
NAFTA corporations.
And this region is the only one
prepared to compete
with the East--
with Asia, with China.
We have to save
the Western values right here
-in North America.
-Okay, now...
(cheering and applause)
This book is focused on America.
-Yes, sir. -You're an outsider,
who, obviously,
has a lot of love and care
for this country.
I love hearing
about how great America is.
What... Why write a book
about America?
What-what is it that you see
here that makes you want
to-to help, as you put it?
Uh, I would say harm,
but-but I think you call it help
in this book.
What is it?
This half you see here
in front of you
has American blood.
My grandfather
was born in Cincinnati, Ohio,
and he came as a migrant
down to Mexico.
He rode all along,
and he settled in Guanajuato,
where we are.
And his dream became true
by coming to Mexico.
We've been there
for five generations.
I love this nation.
America's great.
It's already great.
And it will keep on being great,
as soon as you get rid
of this guy.
(laughter)
(cheering and applause)
Is what you're trying to say,
we need to make America great
again?
(laughter)